what do these by-election results mean
for boris johnson well two damaging
defeats one to labour in wakefield in
west yorkshire part of the symbolic red
wall and the other to the lib dems in
tibetan and huntington in desert the
safest of conservative seats and then
another blow at 5 30 this morning the
conservative party chairman oliver
dowden once a staunch ally of the prime
minister resigned saying someone needs
to take responsibility now the prime
minister himself shows no signs of
wanting to throw in the towel but there
are big questions about what happens
next
[Music]
while boris johnson survived a
confidence vote at the start of this
month i can announce that the
parliamentary party does have confidence
so in theory he can't face another one
for another year but the question
conservatives will be asking themselves
this morning is will more cabinet
ministers follow oliver dowden out of
the door boris johnson is known for
prizing cabinet ministers for their
loyalty so if any did it would be a
major possibly fatal blow
[Music]
could tory mps make another move against
the prime minister well they're
considering changing their rules to
allow another challenge and perhaps the
threat of losing seats to the liberal
democrats in the south and labour in the
north and a pincer movement could focus
their minds but even if they were
successful in changing those rules
there's no real successor that the party
are uniting around or any agreement or
what direction the party should go in
[Music]
is there more danger on the horizon well
boris johnson is adamant he's going
nowhere and if no one else resigns he
looks safe until the summer recess but
in the autumn there are more
difficulties the privileges committee of
mps will report into whether he misled
parliament over partygate boris johnson
your contempt for this country is no
longer tolerated and his team will need
to prepare for a general election
overshadowed by a cost of living crisis